ladies and gentlemen of the reject Nation I'm
only here to introduce this video to tell you
that everything you're about to hear is so stupid
this is all this is all true I can't believe it
get away Corey as some of you may know I host a
show a corner if you will of this very Network
called koi's Comic Corner as others of you may
know I uh discuss comic books for a living and
comic book movies and as you're all about to
find out I've never seen Superman the movie
in my life I made a list of the top
25 comic films of all time and upon
reviewing the comments went I just didn't
think Superman was that great and then went
I don't think I've seen Superman and then Greg
and I started talking and he asked me what the
plot of Superman was and I didn't know I've never
seen Superman the movie so you dear citizens of
the reject Nation are ready to join me as I find
out can a man fly will I believe it hit the like
hit or hit a comment below yell at me it's
inevitable let's see where this ranks in my
movie comic experience having never seen it and
if you'd like to do a full feature length sync
it up with me watch it alongside check out the
patreon this whole thing's gonna be there and
this movie is very short and this is the very
last thing I'm doing this leads right up to my
birthday this is how I'm ending my my year let's
find out Christopher Reeve I hear he's pretty good
and at times of fear and confusion
the job of informing the public is
the responsibility of the Daily Planet
a great Metropolitan newspaper whose
reputation for clarity and Truth great
intro I like that this feels historic
and I imagine even felt historic then
like it feels Timeless and and important
that was cool foreign
man I love Miniatures that's pretty
these are matters of undeniable fact
take down to bring in their presence
the vote must be unanimous to her
you alone will condemn us if you wish and you
alone will be held responsible by me you will
about all before material I swear it both you and
then one day your ass this is so extreme in its
composition the Sci-Fi elements are a lot and then
the visual composition they don't make a lot of
movies of this scope with that cinematography tell
you that we must evacuate this plan immediately
if not sooner the decision of the council is final
I like the different family crests
it feels lived in feels like there is
history in them but why Earth during their
Primitives thousands of years behind us
virtually invulnerable great exposition
why would we include a piece of kryptonite
that was a great opening performance
I mean it's Marlon Brando
foreign
way to show a planet ending as opposed
to just blindly exploding especially with
what we know the infrastructure of uh The
Fortress of Solitude and some of the comic
imagery of Krypton this is a really
cool way to show the end of Krypton
all right
this must have been surreal
to see in a theater in the 70s
that was beautiful
what was that man pot Kent
vibing we could say he's a child
of my cousin in North Dakota
and just now often now you saw how we found it
that's that's so clever I like that nicely done
that's interesting because this so works
for the time but I wonder how like I feel
like American audiences now are so cynical
I don't know how this would translate maybe
that's why they're having a hard time I love
the hope and the The Whimsy the the earnestness
um maybe a period piece for Superman hey Clark I'm
ready for tomorrow's games okay Mount Vernon High
Lana oh good it is Lana before Lois
I was curious if which storyline
a whole bunch of us are going up to Mary Ellen's
would you like to come sure sounds like it'd be
a lot of fun I got a lot of work to do what are
you talking about I just finished stacking off
all that oh clean this up Clark
oh it's getting bullied Clark Kent
cheesy but cute look there's Clark
that's clever there's one thing I do
know son and that is you are here for
a reason it's not to score touchdowns
good Puck can't wisdom this uh so far has done
an incredible job at the exposition uh and tear
those guys apart is I'm pretty sure straight
from the comic or a comic at least it's got
such honest sensibilities um which again it's
interesting if this would work today oh no
oh no oh
that's heartbreaking it's
just gonna happen like that
oh the heart attack
I knew it had to happen some way and well
that worked for me better than a tornado
did oh what a way to go though good life
lesson pass away quick proud of you kid
ding that hurt hmm why doesn't that
hurt him do you know where you're headed
always remember
so far it's very sweet movie
very sweet as it should be
what's the first fight gonna be I sense a fight
coming polar bear Sea Beast I mean he went North
strange way to get the Metropolis oh of
course the Fortress of Solitude I assumed
using a lot of metropolis I don't know why
this makes way more sense who are you as a man
I assumed it'd be Christopher Reeves all the time
is this Christopher Eve is it already
Christopher Reeves is that Christopher
Reeves is there an age Gap like is
there a time Jump what's happened
fascinated by the relationship with Kryptonite
seems to be some sort of activator in this case
which makes some sense if it also
hurt him does not seem to hurt him
it's like those little geodes you
can grow in a lab I'm your father
the old years interesting if they're just
spelling it out who am I the name is Khalil
you are the only survivor of the Planet
Krypton even though you've been raised
as a human being you are not one of them that
is a cool shot man come with me now my son as
we break through the ball of your Earthly
confinement traveling through time space
in Far exceed those Immortal it has forbidden
for you to interfere with human history
very trippy I like how disorientingly
psychedelic it is at times
for this reason above all their
capacity for good I have sent them you
that was cool I like that
yeah yeah oh that's awesome
okay that was rad I like it
loved that that was such a great way
to come back to do some time playing
to evolve him take note
modern movies that was awesome
how many teasing bloodletting two yeah what
a great Jimmy Olsen how do you spell Massacre
uh m-a-s- in the comic book she historically has
a grammatical and spelling errors even as one of
the greatest Pulitzer prize-winning
uh journalists of all time low
Christopher Reeve it wasn't the same guy uh they
aged him up changed the cast forgot what he looked
like I apologize uh Lois why don't you take Kent
out to uh meet everybody after just introduce him
around great uh body language I know I've seen
the GIF of him like turning into Superman but
it's really impressive to see in the minutia of
uh of the office that's cool I was wondering if
um perhaps you could arrange for half my salary to
be sent to this address on a weekly basis he sends
a check every week to his sweet gray-haired
old mother actually she's silver-haired
there are very few people left
in the world who feel comfortable
saying that word what word as well
I thought it was kind of natural
sorry
I love how clumsy he is to throw people off
it is so good he's incredible as Clark I am
I get it I get it please
don't point that at me sir
sorry now come on lady hand it over
what are you doing
what happened you fainted sorry
he's exceptional make it track 22. I seen him
and I'm right on them lower level track 22.
what a great stooge well-cast little henchman
that baritone of
oh [__]
First Act of Lex Luthor killing a cap sick
Gene hack but not shave his head for Lex Luthor
is that explained maybe that's explained
how many girls do you know who have a Park
Avenue address like this one 200 feet below
do you realize what people are shelling out
up there for a few miserable rooms off a
common elevator what more could anyone ask
Ed
Superman's gonna have to save Lois
it's not good
that's cool like practical
like they messed [__] up
all right
I would get away from there Pope go go
Jurassic Park I see where you
got some of this sequencing from
oh it's just a half
that's good
you've got me who's got you that's where that
line came from I know it from Jay and Silent Bob
yes
foreign
the opposite of uh the Captain America curl is the
straight arm I guess that would be deltoid some
lats extension statistically speaking of course
it's still the safest way to travel he's so
good at Superman who are you a friend bye
all right I believe a man can fly that's freaking
cool especially in 78 this must have blown mines
come on Tom Tom Cruise doing
the work oh that's a cool shot
yes the booty yeah I get the uh the Clark
Kent Superman Duality hype this is impressive
that show is great too take him away
these five minutes of super Manning are better
than a lot of the Superman stuff I've seen foreign
it's not mad he's disappointed
gotta save a kitten what Superman
without saving a kitten here you go Miss
thanks Mister bye frisky long now
bye he's so polite saying eyes and buys a lot of
greetings in the Superman man can this work today
buildings they hire by in regular life
Roger well doesn't look too good what do you think
what the hell what happened not good oh
we lost the whole engine precious yeah
and Superman just said statistically the
safest we got two accidents of metropolis
are nearby come on one human error one
nature it's not safe to fly near Metropolis
a lot of the Superman Returns um imagery plays
a lot better having seen the original because
if any human being we're going to perpetrates
with a fantastic hoax it would have been me
okay good Flex isn't bold I got concerns
I want the inside dope on this guy
has he got a family what is the yes
he's gonna wind up with the single most important
interview since solid casting God talked to Moses
especially without again there's no precedent of
of superhero movies or comic book movies and it
isn't too hokey it's just really sincere and and
it's good it's a good movie sorry to uh drop in
and you like this Miss Lane but I've been thinking
you know there must be a lot of questions about me
that people in the world like to know of course
yes uh you really shouldn't smoke in on this Lane
don't tell me lung cancer right I mean yeah not
yet thank goodness hahaha do you have a girlfriend
uh no I don't but uh if I did Miss Lane
you'd be the first to know about it
is it true that you can see through
anything oh yes it can color underwear
am I wearing this would have a problem with
seeing through lead oh that's interesting
cute this is all very cute come from
a planet called Krypton with a sea no
actually actually it's Krypton
with a k-r-ypt you like pink
very much why are you here there must be
a reason for you to be here yes I'm here
to fight for truth and Justice in the American way
we're gonna end up fighting
every elected official in this
ride with me you mean I can fly yeah actually uh
I'd be handling the flying if that's okay I need
a sweater you must be kind of it's not going to
be warm enough they're very cute good chemistry
it's funny because this feels not quite
like Peter Pan but the the flight style
this does remind me of Peter Pan and windy
yellow yeah this is very cute physics don't
make a lot of sense but it's very cute if
you need a friend I'm the one to fly to
you need to be loved
here I am see that's how you fly with
Superman it's not like a weird touch
thing where it gives you Powers that's that
makes more sense good night oh good night
Superman she said the thing um Lois
we did have a date tonight remember
Lois you haven't been uh
I better get a code no I mean
that's the moment I've seen that's really special
that's some Alexander technique that is that was
beautiful but we've got to go back to being Clark
practical stunts for life
odd look at this dispatch people break into a
museum in the dead of night killed two people
and what do they take a worthless
piece of meteorite how do you figure
that that was found inexplicably
from looking at an encyclopedia
I was a reporter before most
of my friends were copy boys
out his clothes just changed that
doesn't make what what that's not a power
that doesn't make any sense it occurs to
me that a 500 Megaton bomb planted at just
a proper point would would destroy most of
California hello New West Coast my West Coast
Marina Deluxe
millions of people's lives don't matter but uh
well they do but they really do because so does
Lois Lane's life on the fault line it's Kryptonite
Superman little souvenir from the old hometown
we all have our little faults
mine's in California clever
good use of pun faulty word play
Lex my mother lives in Hackensack
dark if I help you to prompts to save
my mother first I promise I promise
top gun Maverick
I did not expect it to actually detonate
oh he's gonna go back in time he's got
a uh because they're not supposed to meddle uh
human history but I imagine he'll rationalize it
happy birthday
this is pretty rad like scope for the third Act
that's impressive special effects
come on Superman put them
all back together Amazing
Spider-Man 33 cover but with Superman
lifting the entire San Andreas Fault
and still saving the children okay
kids all right now hey it's Superman
gotta keep diving in holes Superman I guess must
be another movie where you guys are back in time
get out of there Jimmy
a noble tradition begins
oh no we're into a single
that is terrifying cool
practical effects to have that
the claustrophobia is real
nope nope don't like that
oh those are little Miniatures look
at them I can only tell because it's
in like 4K but that was a really
cool use of practical into managers
it is so dark that he's helping this
saving people but drowning Lois in rocks
man the tension I know she's gonna
be fine but man it's great great work
no way do they kill Lois in the first
movie and then he flies back in time
is that what's happening do they kill
Lois Lane in that horrific terrifying
claustrophobia inducing buried alive way foreign
gotta stand against his father's wishes
oh
he may be fast enough to reverse time but
he's not fast enough to fight fast enough over
those mountain ridges to save her simultaneously
while she's you know being buried alive that's so
cool look at those effects I love reverse
photography like that come on Superman
so he's already stopping us a
one at this point there he is
can't believe they killed Lois movie
one Superman cares about everybody Jimmy
but who knows someday you know if he's lucky
just flies him into prison
so they never showed Gene Hackman actually bald
they just imply he's always wearing wigs oh I was
Luther they saved it for the last appearance
I believe a man can fly I like that
look at that Alex Ross painting come to life well
this proceeded Alex Ross's
paintings but look at that
that reminded me a lot of Superman blue which
came out much later uh that reminded me a lot
of All-Star Superman also came out much later
it was my two reading recommendations for y'all
All-Star Superman and uh Superman blue I really
enjoyed that I can't believe I'd never seen it
I think I'd maybe seen I don't know obviously
the gifts uh and and maybe five minutes on like
TNT growing up but I didn't remember the plot I'd
obviously seen the you know the reversing of the
planet in pop culture but I kept doubting myself
as to when it was uh so I liked it a lot it will
likely rank in my 26 to 50 which we're going to
convince Greg to let me do um it's probably in
the top 20 of superhero movies but I would not
put in my top 10 uh there's probably like 250
comic movies so top 20 would be that 26 to 50. um
I I see why it's beloved I definitely like have so
much reverence for it it influenced so many things
uh it did drive me crazy and this is a problem I
have a lot of movies um when there's two movies
uh that don't feel like they're one movie I love
when movies feel like you know disparate movies
that all come together at the end but at no point
did it feel like Gene Hackman's Lex Luthor was in
the same movie as Christopher Reeves Superman uh I
really enjoyed the Christopher of Superman movie
and I really enjoyed his relationship with Lois
I really enjoyed the magic and and earnesty and
sheer honesty and almost this golly gee Shucks uh
Whimsy of the Superman movie but the reason that
worked is because it was Earnest in its honesty
and I feel like the Gene Hackman Lex Luthor was a
satirical play on 50s um editorial comic books it
felt like it was making a commentary on the golden
age uh comic book uh Sunday newspaper era and so
it felt like there was there was two different
performances happening and the one I enjoyed
fit with Marlon Brando fit with the backstory fit
with all these things but whenever they cut the
likes it didn't feel like the same movie and even
the scenes with Superman and Lex felt a little
disjointed so um everything with Superman I really
loved uh I would probably give and like that's
it with the times and everything else the special
effects really special loved the use of Miniatures
loved how tangible it felt loved the scope loved
the uh Power of the score love the the feel of
the movie they don't make movies like this where
you feel so much and I think the reason it's so
hard to make a Superman movie is because you need
that golly gee man this guy's a Boy Scout man I
believe in him the physicality between Clark Kent
and Superman was so special I'm really excited to
see that dick Donner cut a Superman too to be
honest now that I've seen this uh this probably
lands like a four stars for me um this is like
a B plus a minus this will likely Fall in that
26 to 50 of of superhero movies need to look at
the rest of my rankings I'm gonna continue that
ranking to build it out because I want to know
where this lands but I'm really glad to have
seen it I definitely have not seen this one which
means I definitely haven't seen Superman two three
or four uh I'm gonna go B plus a minus I'm gonna
go four stars really really special film I see
why it's revered I cannot imagine watching it
then I can't like I got so many moments of of
whoa and wonder and and Power in 2022 I cannot
imagine seeing this 35 years ago 34 for the new
math Wizards 34 years ago uh just what this must
have been so incredible film I see why it's a lot
of people's top ten I see why everyone yelled at
me in the chat I deserve to get those comments but
now I've seen it and uh four stars really really
spectacular experience things that really worked
were Margot Kidder and Christopher Lee the things
that worked Margo Kidder and Christopher Lee's
relationship I thought was really special uh Jimmy
Olsen though a small part was very very integral
to both building the world and establishing how
people would perceive Superman from that like
eye line uh Perry White and The Daily Planet
everything with the Daily Planet really worked
um I was really impressed at the Clark Kent
Duality I kept thinking how impressive that
was uh we're now in the closing credits and
Marlon Brando and Gene Hackman are both billed of
Chris free that is fascinating also I kept seeing
someone walk around the mustache that I felt like
must be someone that would end up later and it
looks just like um Kiefer Sutherlands now Donald
Sutherland I don't think Donald Sutherland was in
this but I kept seeing an almost Donald Sutherland
walking around the streets of metropolis
like twice he popped up I haven't pointed out
um yeah I I was just so so impressed with the
world built um I was so impressed with what
it was able to do with Exposition it unloaded
so much Exposition on you it gave you Marlon
Brando Exposition it gave you lots and lots of
Fairly hokey uh Lex Luthor Exposition it gave
you lots of where Superman came from and what his
powers are um didn't love the sometimes powers are
convenient like the speed thing is obviously
hard to clock but it did bother me that he
couldn't get to her in time but could turn the
plan I get it is you know dramatic uh and I get
that's necessary for the storytelling but I wish
there was something else that impeded him maybe
um Kryptonite poisoning uh something slowed him
down he had to shake it I don't know I don't know
um I'm not writing Superman 1978 over uh and
another another slight qualm um was the weird
power to change clothes in the sky uh one of
the special things of Superman is those grounded
moments like the photo booth and things so that
that was odd uh I couldn't tell if he could read
minds at one point um it was like she was thinking
and wondering if she if he was reading her mind
sometimes his body language seemed to imply that
he could read her mind I could not quite tell what
was happening there um but those are all minor
qualms like that's me looking for things uh to
be bothered by or to you know feel about it um
I don't know if I'd seen it um at any different
point in my life that would change I was really
trying consciously to look at this objectively
regardless of seeing in 2022 versus seeing it
as a child uh I think I definitely would have
loved it as much as I loved it now as a kid uh
I think I would have gotten the same sense of
wonder uh it definitely endears me to dick down or
even more Richard Donner's always been one of my
favorite directors the Lethal Weapon franchise
is one of my all-time favorite franchises ever
um dick Downer and Schumacher were really good
friends and those are two of my favorite directors
and they uh you know uh calibrated they uh they
coordinated a lot they collaborated that's what
I was looking for it's late they collaborated
a lot and this reminded me of how special of a
filmmaker because it's hard you don't often
get to see new works of old works of your
favorite filmmaker so it was really special to
see uh Richard Donner film I hadn't seen before
especially one as iconic as this uh and it lived
up to the very lofty expectations of what Superman
the movie had to be to have all that reference
I don't know why they saved bald's gym the very
end I wonder if I was like scheduling stuff but
uh yeah got a whole lot out of it really really
I'm glad to have seen it really curious about
the second one really curious where it falls off
apparently with the third and fourth uh I haven't
seen Superman Returns the Brandon Routh Superman
since theaters so I think the last time I saw
that would have been 0607 whenever that came out
um so that's 15 years ago at this point so it'd
be really cool to watch Superman 2 probably the
dick Donner cut and then watch Superman Returns
as sort of a Trilogy so that's what I might do
with uh with this series so if you want to see
that leave a comment below if you enjoyed this
if you've got any notes as to why the bald cap or
uh the power adjustments and those things that I
had tiny qualms with please do let me know uh and
let me know what you think of this this re-watch
of a movie 34 years ago is cool to do something
so classic and so different that I just somehow
didn't see in my 33 years I'm turning 34 at
midnight in a few minutes and that was a 34
year old movie feels like fate don't it uh all
right that is gonna do what you love please I
appreciate y'all very very much please do leave
a like leave a comment subscribe to this very
Channel if you want to see me more uh on these
giant rewatches of Full Features let me know if
you want me to watch Superman 2 let me know if you
think I should do Superman one and Superman 2 and
then Batman Batman return Superman Returns let me
know let Greg know you want me to do 26 through 50
so I can rank this here film somewhere in there I
do think it's going to fall in that 26 to 50 range
um there's a lot of four star uh comic book films
for me and uh this is definitely in there this
is gonna be up there but you know in that top top
20 of all of them uh all right like I said that's
gonna do it your lovelies have a great night we'll
see you hopefully for Superman too comment foreign